welcome to the recruitment mentors
podcast my name is
hisham azuz today i'm really excited to
be joined by michael young who is the
ceo
of nbn solutions who are an innovative
disruptive recruitment talent and people
solutions consultancy
they operate globally and work with a
range of companies throughout scotland
uk europe us and beyond
from the very beginning of michael
starting his own recruitment business
he's been
really focused on building communities
within his industry so
with that approach he's ended up
founding countless tech
meetups such as the scotland data and
science meetup
to the scottish blockchain up
something that i know michael's really
proud of is that his business has been
involved in a government scheme
where they helped companies like the
data lab innovation center
who are on a mission to help scotland
maximize value from data
and lead the world to a data powered
future with local msc
students and i know a sort of stat that
michael's really proud of is the
nbn have actually been involved in
helping kickstart 350
students to get into the industry um as
part of that scheme as well which i
think is absolutely amazing so
michael welcome to the podcast thank you
for joining me
thanks very much awesome so where we
always like to start on this uh
show is the the million pound question
which is in your opinion what
characteristics and traits do you think
make up a highly successful recruitment
consultant
i think working throughout the years
with with some really
successful recruitment consultants that
over over time there's been a few traits
that have really
stuck out to me and and played in my
mind and i think
one of them is is people not just been
in it for the for the short game
no knowing knowing that this is a career
and really mastering their trade
i've seen people come around and really
taking a first even year maybe even
two years to really get to know their
markets get to know well build
communities
and become really well known within the
within that market
not just as someone who fills jobs but
somebody who
actually really knows what they're
talking about and can talk
in depth with managers and companies
about that and again back to
the old cliche that resilience obviously
massive
it can be a tough tough job especially
at the start when you're really learning
your trade so
yeah and having that well to not give up
i love that yeah so having a long-term
mindset
yeah not not being transactional yeah i
love that so
where we're gonna take this conversation
obviously michael
uh founded his own recruitment business
in 2007 so for the last sort of 14
to nearly 15 years now michael's been
really focused on building
nbn solutions so we're going to really
unpack that
and the sort of things that you've
learned um along the way
up until now but very very quickly
always interested to find out
and i know people interested to hear
like what how would you describe
obviously so from what i can see you've
been in the industry from 2000
um like how would you describe
the early years of michael's recruitment
career like what what did that look like
how would you describe it
yeah it was but again like a lot of
others i was
i went back to university actually back
when i was about 20 so i could have
lately
i was a welder before that and really
yeah
i'm back taking college in university
1920 and i hadn't even
had never switched a computer on so
that's that's how far back it was so
back to urine
and did but i just did some i t then i
was doing part-time tele sales at bt so
i really liked the sales
side of things but i think it's probably
as soon as i put my cv on job boards
without the
the little bit of i.t and some daily
sales i'd have a direct direct
and they were all foreign
and and what it would be like so i'll
move to bristol and
started my recruitment career i actually
started
with any high street recruiters for the
first
two and a half years yeah it's great
it's quite a strange journey but when i
was doing high street recruitment
i moved in a little bit of can i wrecked
her egg myself and i
started yeah i started finding a
a tech engineering startup recruiter
a recruitment consultant and when i was
going down and meeting them and and
talking
about the job and earning potential and
what it was like in the environment i
really
loved it loved the sound of that myself
so i approached it myself and asked out
for a job
and again back then i wasn't their usual
hire i wasn't making a fresh grad
21 year old football canal that kind of
stuff that's what it seemed to be like
back then it was actually a
certain person a lot of people would
take on but they come they took
out took it upon on me and i was at that
kind of time in my career i was actually
getting close to
god close to fair at a time so really
yeah i was ready i must yeah i must have
been late twenties
anyway definitely late twenties but i
was at accurate stage i really wanted to
go in and try to make something of
myself and really
just just do it do i had to do it to
succeed and i think that they could
they got that from them so from doing a
few years
high street equipment removed a company
who there was only
four or five of them at the time there
are multi global
multi-million pound business now but the
two founders
had probably just left jobs where they'd
probably make about a quarter of a
million to start off in a small
a small office so it was it was it was a
real hardcore environment
and i loved it what do you love about it
i just loved it i probably was doing the
high street stuff and i didn't really i
wasn't really getting taught how to
sell and clothes and what clients and
really know what i was doing and
the focus sales process and i moved in
in a totally different environment and
and i really loved that
just the environment how fast-paced it
was how quite
it was just it was a real push i had a
manager
probably worked with me for three to six
months more or less sitting with me just
less than
everything i was doing and coaching me
and helping me
i know a lot of people don't like that
like that kind of micro management but
i can i can say now that what i under
that first six months has set me up to
where i am today and if i never had that
i don't know where i would be today it
was it was amazing
i learned so much in that first six
months to a year with with a great
manager
who was it
in a contract office so i was getting
just i was interested
yeah i could choose what i wanted to
work i think
i think that's what i think that's one
of the like greatest things about
working for a small gram
business i think and i know you'll
probably partner and work with startups
and stuff like that but particularly in
recruitment in that environment i mean i
joined the
yeah office of light i think six people
when i joined and
it didn't end up being a great a massive
business but i sat
next to the owner of the business who
was ex haze worked his way
up and like you just learned so much so
i guess
i'd be stupid not to ask like if you
were to like in
like looking back at that time if you
could maybe condense it to like maybe
two or three like
key things that you feel has really kept
with you that has had a really impact a
real impact on your recruitment career
what would
you say the two three things you learned
that you think has really
sort of given you the best chance of
like winning in recruitment of interest
i think one of the as soon as i joined
there was a
i was a three-page job spec it was
actually sellotaped
to my desk and again speaking to my
manager he told me it took him about two
years to
really master listed to master it in
detail so that
when he was like any any job he would
get he would fill
because the job spec would be it would
just be amazing listen to these people
taking these at the time so that was new
to me so
so can i master them that which you've
got a job spec but it's everything from
creating troll fighter to speak to the
right person so
so masked on that was the best thing so
just so i
wasn't very clear on that so when you
said job spec what do you mean sorry as
in taking a job or what do you mean
yeah so it was just just that as in when
you first introdu introduce yourself to
a client and they've got
a job i can remember during that early
days and some of my
job specs were that would be recorded at
the time and i listened back now and it
was just i was an absolute robot at the
start just trying to read off a scrap
so getting comfortable with that and
being able to kind of guide calls and
and find as much information as possible
from clients was
was one of the first things that really
helped me
then again then again urgency again just
really making things happen uh
probably again sitting in high street
sitting in the disney no high streets
that i still don't
the first few jobs i was in uh
there was no one i wouldn't influence
anything but if the client says
somebody was i know or if i can't did it
wasn't interested in that conversation
would finish there but
but really i meant to go on and and
influence and
and and make them make decisions happen
which was massive for me as well so
a few of the key things for me as well
yeah i love that
so just quickly just out of curiosity
because
i have my own opinion on this but like
how what are your views on like scripts
out of interest like i don't like yeah
what do you think because i
go on definitely not fighting on scripts
at all but
i think uh maybe the first two or three
months
when people are really learning their
trade it's not it's not a bad thing just
to have a reference there in front of
them when they're maybe getting a little
bit
tongue twisted mixed up and in a
difficult situation where they can maybe
go back and
help them guide the conversation but
again it's about making it your own
that's why
i think i mentioned when at the start
they
i was talk to lamb and say don't didn't
know what so it wasn't like a script
then i could jump in
the middle to the back to the front and
really make it
make it my own so i think good good to
maybe help guide some conversations at
the start
yeah i think the the thing what i the
thing what i really like and i
i do this now when i'm speaking to
businesses about
recruitment mentors i think there's a
lot to be said to like i think
most people let's say for example i was
i don't know maybe specking out a
candidate
or i was trying to get hold of a
particular candidate that i know has
great skills and great experience
but personally i do feel like there's a
lot to be said to actually
make the time to understand like what
types of pains and things that you're
going to highlight or talk about and
communicate that in the right way
because i think if you go into like a
candidate spec called going to
headhunting
or even a cult or whatever and like
you're just relying on
understanding what you need to say
rather than like just thinking about or
knowing the sort of core of what you
want to get across i think you're just
making it more difficult for yourself
and i think if you were to say maybe to
say to your team now
like if you were to like speak to a
client for the very first time what
would be your like elevator pitch
how many of them would be able to rule
that out don't know and that's just
super valuable
because like you you need to think about
the pains
the the real pains that obviously you
can solve
and all those sorts of things and i
think there's a lot to be said to like
just
for maybe things that you do a lot of
the time specking out cvs
introducing yourself it's worth thinking
of like okay what what is my message in
that
and then i don't know i
through different scenarios and really
trained quite heavily on that so
yeah people are prepared to get what
they need yeah i think yeah
definitely help a lot early on as well
if you listen to this and early on
definitely think about
what do i typically always say on these
calls and just write it down make sure
you're happy with it and have something
that you can lean on before you like
really master it
i think um so i guess
to sort of finalize this then obviously
you've now hired plenty of people for
your own business like what
what would your advice be for people um
who are early on in that sort of
recruitment journey
to like really maximize the opportunity
that they have so like let's say i'm
listening to this i'm in my first year
maybe the first two years like what
would your advice be to me
the if i have aspirations to be a top
biller be sort of do really great what
would you be saying to me do you think
i would i would say really really try
and look at
a niche and be the best in that niche
and
don't just rely on your day job take
time go to meet-ups set up your day
set up your own meetups learn from
others
attend events and really get to know
your market
inside out and get to know the people in
it take time and
build build communities and and networks
and
get to know candidates the best people i
work with now if they get a job within
their
niche market they're not going to job
boards and going going to
uh a lot of their crms i've been maybe
know 10 15 people who they can talk who
they can call on straight away
who either be good for the job but who
know people follow the job because
they're quite
because they've built respect and trust
in in their markets i think that's so
important
yeah and i know a lot of people ever own
an equipment there is a lot of
i've seen it throughout the years myself
and ours there's a lot of imposter
syndrome
within recruitment consultants as well
early on they think they're on a year
and
that's not speaking to maybe chief data
offers and see senior
data people and and they don't feel that
they're in the position to really
get dealing dealing with them as well so
but if
you can get that out of your head as
soon as you possibly can i can remember
it was
massive for me for a couple of years it
was quite daunting going and speaking
going and meeting people who were like
senior directors within date and
analytics within
big businesses i was going to just when
i was at learning recruitment so i think
that's
really confidence yeah and believe me
believe in what you do yeah
so couple of things and we'll go into
you um starting your own recruitment
business
which i find really interesting we just
shared there so
so the first thing just always
interested to hear people's opinions on
this and it's come up a lot on this
podcast
so having a niche yeah like what what's
your definition of
like like what would be like to go i
mean like in your opinion
what is like niche enough out of
interest like how would you just talk to
me about that because i think that'll be
interesting for people definitely
so you can go you can go really really
nice some people are doing that some
people are doing amazing i've heard
about some
companies they selling their businesses
recently have been really niche begins
nine times multipliers as well on that
yeah but
yeah software development there used to
be as if you're a software development
consultant you would cover
all aspects of software development but
now we've got a few people doing
software development development and
world just to just cover
either javascript i've done that java so
that will that will take it right down
to that i think you need to do that as
well
we do a lot of uh within we we're going
to date science recruiter as well so
really mixing it down to like computer
vision which is massive that's a
multi-billion pound industry on its own
and really ignition it down as far as
you possibly can
okay just getting really getting to know
that market
yeah yeah so i guess if we were to turn
that into a lot of football analogy then
yeah and see with it being there the
euros yeah
well when when this goes out the euros
might answer it yeah be interested to
see so i guess so just to make this
really clear then so like maybe
yeah if you're someone that's listened
to this and let's say that you're
someone that recruits football players
for the premier league like that what
michael's saying here is that
potentially isn't niche enough so
actually you want to go a step
further and go i recruit football
players for the premier league and i
only recruit
right-backs and left-back full-backs it
might just be that you know what i'm in
and it's like taking that step further
isn't it and and
i guess like obviously the advantage of
that from what you're sharing is like
that if you do that and just stay in
that lane
like the you're going to have even more
better chance of like really
understanding who the main players are
in that market
where the talent is where to go for the
talent so when you do
so everyone wants to be that go-to
person in that space and
yeah it's about really making sure that
you're giving yourself
enough um if there if it is that niche
then you're going to have more
opportunity to really know that market
inside out whereas if it's
still too wide it's going to be hard to
like really
be known and you can understand it all
you i i'm i've worked with some people
involved on me are starting to make it
look
easy at the moment because but it but
this is maybe five
six years of really working in a
country to start with within a niche and
and
really take the time to get to get to
know people but again it takes trust as
well we need to really deliver on this
and it could be a couple of years of
delivering then you need to have the you
need
the personality to go on with people in
in
relationships and most i'm i'm still
working with
my place my first ever analyst in 2005
and i still talked to the the hiring
manager and the person i placed
every other month
there was a small team of data
professionals with a place then
lloyd's
and then just two final things sorry so
one one thing is just
out of curiosity how how have you gone
up because you i'm sure you've done this
with your business now
what what's your thought process and
advice on like identifying a niche like
a profitable niche like maybe not
profitable right word but like
a niche that you would get excited about
where you see opportunity if you go i
mean like how what's your like
identifica like what do you typically
look for to go you know what
if we had someone just focused on that
in two three four years time that could
be a really strong part of our
recruitment business
definitely you can look at a lot of
different market trades market trends
what's happening in the press
look at like what companies are getting
bored where the startups are coming from
as well
especially around a bit like a
healthcare in nai
and machine learning and stuff like that
and you can look at
talk to other people see how look at
other businesses look at other
recruiters
see how well they're doing within
certain issues as well and just follow
trend there
okay so just market trends yeah but
again just
you can't just jump into a nation think
you're going to be a master i know
within like
three to six months yeah yeah
loads of tech recruiters come into the
data market they are just
as soon as it really started booming and
they were just going to
explain themselves as data recruiters
just because they've done it equipment
for a while but it
is totally different as well and at this
point it takes time
then the other thing i just wanted to
make sure that i asked you because i i
completely agree because i've seen this
a lot when working with recruiters
on like recruiters that are sort of
quite early on in their career on like
helping them market themselves more
effectively
but one of the biggest obstacles that
they have for themselves
is like that imposter syndrome peace or
like they don't feel like
they're i don't know i don't know if the
right words worthy but they don't think
they're credible enough
to like be talking about that yeah so
just talk to me because i'm sure you've
had to help
obviously people on your team work for
years like you can talk about
yourself or like like how if i'm
listening to this and maybe i'm
struggling with that
yeah like how what are the typical
things that one helps you work through
that to gain more confidence or to
that you've been doing with your
employees that have helped them work
through that
definitely a lot of it oh god that's one
of the biggest things within our
businesses
at the moment is trying people are doing
amazing things even with some people
they look podcasts and writing
excellent stuff but that's they still
won't put their name against it say
this is an excellent project i've been
working on it it's
a lot of it's just it's confidence and
some
sometimes it's maybe going and looking
at different there's
you might have to go out and look at
some personal development and it's not
always recruitment training it can help
with this there might be other self
development courses around about
confidence and
and stuff like that as well it's a very
very hard one i know
personally for myself it was i had been
in recruitment three four years i wasn't
really
any all that at all but it was one
second i started my own business and i
had to do that if that makes sense i
really had to
i had to go i need to start building a
personal brand here and
i think a lot of it i don't know if it
kind of maybe came with me through
maybe just can i get maturity and i'll
be back more confident within myself
because it's
yeah it's it's my so some people have
really really got it early on day one
they'll come in
you see what they're doing and but but
you need to be really authentic about it
as well if
you need you need to be it needs to
sound like you
and be you because people see through
that as well
it's a hard one to give advice am i just
trying we just try and teach people
slowly but surely build it up
uh um it's something i'm really looking
at at the moment is people's own
personal branding yeah i think i think
uh
what i what i would say and it'd be good
to get your thoughts is
yeah i think and i definitely struggle
with this so i think
sometimes recruiters can get too caught
up on like
what they're not knowledgeable on and
explain what i mean
so let's say i enter the tech market
tomorrow
and i want to be seen as like the go-to
person
and the expert obviously one i'm not
going to be an expert overnight that's
just
that's just part of the process but i
think sometimes what recruiters forget
is let's say that my niche
is yeah javascript developers like
the insight and the value that you have
is actually the amount of
javascript developers that you speak to
on a daily weekly basis and the insight
that you get from that
rather than you're never going to know
as much as that javascript developer
about writing code like that and i think
sometimes that's where recruiters get a
bit caught up because they think
are for me to be talking about this or
for me to bring this person and be on
the level with them
i need to i'm not as competent as them
or but like recruiters don't get paid to
do
the work you're never going to get paid
to do what your candidates do right
the insight and the value that you have
which is why you should view as you're
both sitting on this at the same table
no one's had another is that actually
the huge value that you offer is i speak
to x number of people
like you every single day how many
people do you speak to
like yourself oh you know what boys only
a couple of people my team got a couple
of friends it might be under 10 people
well
i speak to 10 people a day like you so
the value and insight that i have and
where i'm an expert is understanding
what's going on and i think it's that
that sometimes people get mixed up on
it's like what
they're like experts in yeah because i
couldn't agree more again
honestly i couldn't agree more i could
remember at the start with this crazy
data science world thinking i had to
talk about
stuff like that and it was definitely
not me but i think people are getting
the value when they're talking about
clients or maybe tunda
could have maybe turned around a
contract vacancy within 24 hours
our clients are maybe taking two weeks
to to make an offer so it's talking
about what you're seeing in that stuff
as well
yeah exactly it's it's it's all that
kind of stuff you definitely don't need
to be talking about
technical stuff but you might know of
skills
yeah you know skills that are starting
to that you start to see that in the
marketing clients are taking on like
notice trends like
and stuff like that it's
yeah yeah exactly that's the information
so like when you're saying you need to
know your
market inside out embed yourself in it
that doesn't mean by the end of it
15 years later you're going to be able
to do what they do it's more about
yeah like understanding the trends
what's going on what good companies are
doing and all these sorts of things
okay let's let's talk about
nbn solutions then so obviously
started that in 2007 yeah obviously
uh worked in for a obviously a couple of
different recruitment businesses
well i i always start here because
a lot of people and i'm sure you've been
in these conversations will be down in
the pub or wherever it is going on
imagine if i was making all this money
for myself and
wasn't employed doing all that like what
what gave you the confidence to take
that first step and actually
start do you think definitely so
probably always wanted to always said
that we can entrepreneurial kind of
thing about me even when i
was younger when i was doing i was
welding and at school i used to see the
kind of people on the trains going into
business and
i always said that was nothing about me
for an hour and age wanted to be an
entrepreneur so
i thought it was a good opportunity for
me i was looking up
in bristol probably could have had my
fairies and
i was i just felt as if it was time to
move back to scotland the situation was
the situation was good for me so
yeah after five great years in bristol
and i moved back to glasgow
and i had the opportunity to to start on
my own uh
and i actually got my mom to my mom
actually got me a ten thousand pound
bank loan at the time
to get it so she could have got me that
helped me get up it was all colleague i
think database helped me get kind of set
up on that and
how much of a runway did that give you
okay
it probably gave us a couple of months i
had a
there was a there's a really well-known
businessman
in glasgow absolute general another guy
who gives up a back room just an office
in there
use the office and phones and stuff in
an old computer there so we had that
and it was just a few licenses and stuff
back then at the days it was totally
different it was
you would go in and my first ever deal
placement was we were like gala
coral based down and not based down in
northern
but my second and third and fourth deal
were within that department within
people they had worked with so it was
more just about
it was more just networking and
referrals how long did it tell you to do
the deal
i think i was done in
the first month anyway i was off i was
i'm running quick
i was scared was it good times back then
as just as it is right now
yeah you know i was i was again i was i
had
so much kind of fear of failure i was i
would not have i have always could have
been that way
they talk about some of the situations
i've had and starting business in some
of the stresses
which i know probably 99 percent of
people would just pack it in and go
go work for a bike organization but i
was i was on it i was just i
gave it 100 percent i was really willing
to make it
i wouldn't have failed no matter what
but i didn't have a clue what i was
doing
i've never managed i'd never managed
anybody in my life
didn't know about finance accounts back
office marketing
anything like that at all so i had no
real knowledge of a business and running
teams and running
p l's and all that kind of stuff i just
knew okay can i go on a phone
and again they all said a lot
so probably never growing scaled as
quick as
i could have because it was just hiring
a few people and
getting things in place then after a few
years of probably really banging my head
off of all the different things i've
started to get out for more external
help with non-execs and
and other things and support with
accounts and finance when i first
started the business
that i counted somebody recommended them
and i used to go down a business it was
decent cash at the time i used to get
there just they just had me a one-page
report
here you go told me nothing told me i
was like nothing so
isn't it crazy so let's break this down
a bit over the next sort of 30 minutes
let's break this down obviously 14 years
is i'm sure it just feels like a big
sort of
blur like this all of this right so so
let's just talk about
i guess a good question to start is that
would give value to people is
i guess you've got the benefit of
hindsight now right so
thinking looking back now if you were to
start those first couple of years again
and start a recruitment business again i
guess
what sort of things would you maybe do
differently what would you invest in
sooner rather than later talk to us
about
maybe what you would do differently at
the beginning of that journey that you
think would have had a
positive impact so i think i would i
would put
i wouldn't put all my eggs in the
baskets and all emphasis on just
sales and doing deals and uh bringing in
the top sales people they're the most
important people you can have in a
business
because i was i was just so focused on
sales and
bringing in top bars and getting people
up and running and
and i really lost track on the things
that are
so important to me now i've actually
been back after 15 14 years
and i've just brought in for vegetarian
now and
so 100 nearly we're supposed to get 100
system compliance
before uh we're looking at other other
systems like that
and i saw i would put a lot more
emphasis on real processes
and systems and
why would that have helped why would
that have helped out of interest because
i feel like they're the types of yeah
can go out the window you're like i
would do that when we're like 10 15
people
like why would that have helped it would
just help you get to 10
10 15 people much quicker when you
interview yourself you have all your
kind of systems and your operations team
and place to make things run a lot a lot
smoother as well you'd be fully
compliant as well
uh you would you would have a rep
repetitive system where you could just
plug new people into it as well
and it would work for you you would know
your clients better we've invested
heavily this year last just telling the
last year on
i've brought in a business-to-business
marketeer non-recruitment background
and and i believe he's going to really
transform our business in terms of lead
generation
and knowing our customers we're looking
at a very very exciting project at the
moment
based on kind of account management
because we're looking at
let's just go and hire a big senior
account manager bring something at that
said you'll solve everything but we'll
we'll work within our marketing and our
md and client services director to say
we we don't know after 14 years we don't
have our update is not in a place yet to
bring somebody senior in to do account
management
so we're working on a cracking project
at the moment all of it
on board then but it's it's marketing
led
through configurable hubspot and venturi
just to really
to get more customers outside out it's
been fun it's been a fascinating
this year has been a fascinating journey
with within operations
bringing in vegetari looking at looking
at what we're doing with marketing and
and and i guess that's really going to
we're on boarding people much easier at
the moment as well our systems are
really in place
and it's allowed us now to i've just
told our staff now look
a fully flexible model we'd love to used
to come to our big
beautiful office in glasgow which i'm
always shouting about but the team are
doing absolutely amazing from home at
the moment
we've hired somebody fully remote in
london
we're hiring somebody full remote in
bridge somebody feel remote outside
edinburgh hopefully
and it's really give us a platform for
growth and it's it's just all down to
full system
compliance we could so we've got a
snapshot of our business
straight away it's so important yeah i
love that
yeah really talk to me a bit about
just to try and make this really easy
for
future business owners or current
business owners to understand
yeah talk to me a bit about so like the
you know the systems and process that
you're talking about so
you are you talking about in all areas
of your business so if we sign
so let's say that we so we partner with
a new business
this is what that system looks like
going from signing terms
to onboarding them um or
are you also talking about systems on
okay if we hire someone new for the
business tomorrow
this is sort of what they have to do
we're also talking about systems of
this is how we typically bring this is
how we do new business this is how we
typically source like have systems on
that
but what have been some of the like most
important systems and processes that
you've
implemented or spend time working out
that
yeah sex mods i'm really looking at
everything within the business we've
hired a new because senior operations
manager has been brilliant and we've
actually brought in
a consultant as well who said that years
and years of experience working with
companies who've built a scale country
to country a lot of it is
there's real compliance around the
contractors and stuff
so really all that kind of fully
onboarding
customers as well you would in
recruitment you would on board a lot of
customers and you would maybe here you
would maybe do a placement here a
replacement there and
sometimes sales people are just focused
on getting the deals done as well which
is
which is amazing but we're really
focusing now on knowing our customers
and
and bringing these customers into the
business uh
of so they're sitting with a full
business and they'll
as soon as they they come in as they'll
be fully onboarded within venturi
but they'll also be fully on board they
don't have real onboarding and marketing
process as well so we've taking them on
our journey with white papers
events but at the moment we don't know
our customers well enough to know
exactly what they want so we brought a
marketing person i said give me
another six month and i'll be able to
tell you exactly what these people want
and give them what they want
as well and and and that's what it
really helped massively
cross selling across all our verticals
it's quite an exciting project
in a moment but i thought i knew a lot
about marketing and
well my events and stuff like that and
but i've i've been doing
so much about massive communities
thousands of people
uh but i don't know i don't know my
audience or my assets
at all and and that's what i'm really
working on at the moment now
a massive leak machine as well where a
lot of business will be coming from
systems and marketing a well can
automated and it'll be plugged back into
the sales team
which is so so
what i'm what i'd be really so there's a
couple things i definitely make sure
that we
discuss before we finish so we'll
definitely talk to you about
the community element obviously touch on
that introduction and just talk about
why that's been impactful how it's
impacted your business etc
definitely want to talk to you about the
non-exact getting support a lot of
business owners
a rope and might i feel like more and
more businesses are open minded to
partner with the right ned it's just
actually finding the right entity or
like
like this and then yeah definitely want
to talk to you about hiring culture and
those things
so let's just let's just start with the
community because you're talking a lot
about marketing here
yeah so like obviously from what i can
see
obviously you've yeah started um several
meet-ups in your market right so
why don't we why don't we start by then
like just just making this like
really clear for everyone listening we
may still be cynical and skeptical about
doing stuff like meet-ups like how would
you
like if i was to go michael i'm thinking
about doing this meetup for my market
like what would the pitch to me be like
like how has it impacted your business
like
has it generated revenue what is it
enabled what is it how has it impacted
your recruitment
business definitely so so we're we're
very much community-led with the
strategy day the other week and our
purpose as as people we love people so
the community is very valuable to us
so i started i was doing events in
london with like ebay and asos and ibm
probably around about 2015 and i know a
lot of recruitments are doing
tech and data science events at the
moment but there was nobody doing them
back then
so we were bringing we were bringing 100
data scientists they weren't even a data
scientist back then
big data professionals and empty rooms
and tech professionals and talking about
real industries
the industry we didn't ever want to talk
about recruitment so
really we've really since then we've run
a number of events in london
all over london but in scotland i've
built about i started scoring data
science and technology it's probably
about four and a half thousand
people in it well over four thousand
last time i counted but i started this
in 2015
summer 2015 and i haven't missed a
single month
ever eh since it started and any advice
to anybody
want to start a meet up you need to be
consistent with this
you may get five people four people
three people turning up at the start but
the key is consistency again good
speakers and and
and being consistent since then we've
got a cloud one and a blockchain we've
got over seven thousand people
but the community's been massive for us
the amount of revenue and
new clients we we actually we work with
start-ups and scale-ups
and part of our offering is actually
bringing them into our communities and
letting them
talk about the product to the audience
as well
on our platform i've got scottish
government now
phoning me in a monthly basis now when
new business is moving into scotland
for us to help bring them in to come in
their communities tell them about talent
the price what it's like
and ultimately get get the jobs from
them as well
uh it's it's just it's it's getting us
in front of people every month so
everybody
especially in scotland what everybody
knows about nbn and data
we also do an exclusive roundtable
month every month at the moment there's
maybe 20 people on it
they're like 25 fair it depends the last
one was a big data strategy
and it's in very lonely as well we don't
do a lot on linkedin about it but it's
bringing us in front of the key people
it's what clients will work with for
years and years so it's it's just
helping cement relationships it's the
best thing
i've ever done within business and i
love it as well but sarah
i speak to people everyone for the
coming and talking and
it's that they're the candidates and
clients
we might be able to measure it better
now we've got a relationship yeah so
just really quickly let's like final
thing on that
and i i i totally get this but i want to
make i'll just really want to try and
like and i still think there's so much
opportunity for recruiters to start
things like this there will be people
that start and then like you said won't
be consistent but
i think with like the i feel like the
modern day recruiter will be super nice
so
like if you're like if you're able to
serve your niche
by bringing people together regardless
of how many other recruiters are doing
stuff like this that would be so
valuable for like your niche
right so just really quickly just to
like i just wanted to make this
sound like really as simple as possible
yeah so talk me through
a typical like journey maybe where
there's i don't know let's say that
there's a scale up or start that
you've identified or someone in your
team has identified
in scotland um that you want that you
think
that you guys could work with right talk
to me about
how like how the events would help
like that person or that business become
a client is it
they then get approached to go hey um
may or may not know that we run we're
actually the founders of scotland data
and science wanting to reach out to let
you know that this is a community you
can be part of
we've partnered with lots of like helps
with the bd
we speak and then they maybe attend an
event get involved
they find out a bit more about you i'm
assuming you then maybe follow up or
whatever and then
there's a recruitment conversation at
some point like what is the typical
journey of going
not a client to being a part of the
community and becoming a client just to
spell this out for people like how it
actually
could work so you're building that
relationship for the first call you're
you're really showing them you're
credible within your market
you've talked over the communities
you've built so first of all
and if you're looking to define them
people you're talking about the people
you know within that community
there's four thousand people within
scotland within data we know
a lot of them so that's massive to them
as well yeah and then
and then lots of the if they're typical
start-ups scale up that they will have a
product
that they'll want to get out to the
market as well so we we can allow them
about like the way they we allow them to
come in and talk at the meet-ups and
talk
we tell them to save yourself it's not a
sales pitch but we'll let them
bring them into the community so that
gets their business known
yeah much quicker much quicker than
than than it would in any other
circumstances but you're just you're
cementing that relationship
straight away you're showing them you're
credible you're showing them you know
people within that
industry and and it's just telling them
that
you don't need to go anywhere else to
find the best talent within
this niche market because i'm in it i'm
working on it
i find people in it about events and i
know speakers it's
it's it really helps
and then and then do these people can
these people then literally at some
point go oh
hey like what does mbn do or can nbn
help me with this or like
does it just end up organically going
that way or like do you direct do you
know
like a lot of what are they a lot of the
calls are actually a lot of the calls to
get them into our community and get them
on our
events is led by a a foster conversation
where they're going to be looking to
build the scale and higher
anyway a lot of the majority of them
is led from that if they're going to be
one of our clients an add-on
for us as we can bring them into that
community but again if we're really
targeting people and there's
those we've definitely speak to people
for a long time and we can't get any
and those good a good ways to get them
to come and speak at an event because
you're
you're you're having a conversation for
an hour about the event what it entails
so that there's an instant relationship
built straight away
you know where it can it can lead to
that
yeah i love that and i think that a
common we've had people like talk about
this where it's really impacted their
recruitment desk or business and i think
what i really take from what you're
describing there is like
you're what if you if you take a
potential client through a journey like
that
you're giving you're giving them so much
before you take anything
you know i mean if that's giving them a
platform to tell them about their
product to their target audience or
other people that could help them
or give them direct access to yeah all
these people that could potentially be
great and employees for the yeah there's
just so much that you can give
before you take but and a lot
a lot would have become clients as well
and make you as a competitor but the
on the flip side of that we're bringing
these
great uh business case presentations to
the audience as well
so on the flip side of just the client
side we're bringing this to
the candidates the potential candidates
the community
on a monthly basis as well so you're
just you're
you're in their minds as well and if
they're working they'll usually give me
a shout i don't have one of my
colleagues a show if
one of their colleagues has looked to
hire a senior data person
they have a lot i can sit on a weekly
basis and get
four or five a key level hires emailed
into me through
the community about uh which which could
be passed down on their team to go and
help fill that it's
it's really it's this is making it a lot
easier but i think i love what i do as
well so there is a different i'm quite
passionate about to enjoy it
and i can it gets me out and about
speaking to people and
and i just enjoy that that type of thing
as well so you need to be
again it's like everything you need to
bend that for a long game as well yeah
it's not it's not yeah you don't can't
just start if you think
it's gonna help you yeah like build a
hundred grand or a year like it's gonna
be more than that obviously
um talk to me about talk to me about
your journey with sort of uh ned's then
yeah non-exec directors or getting
support like
talk to me about one i guess how did you
find one
what's been your overall experience how
has it actually
helped you grow this recruitment
business like just talk to us a bit
about that because i know there'll be
a lot of business owners listening on
future business owners thinking about oh
there'll be a lot of things that i'm i
haven't done before and i'd love to get
help like talk to us a bit about
the journey with that i think the the
main
the main thing i could say is really
take your time with this please don't
jump into the first person that comes
it comes to you and maybe sees your a
young start-up recruitment business is
starting to do well because there'll be
a lot of people out there who
really try and hook on to you then who
might not be the best person
for your business to take your time
research them look at their background
speak to people about them please do
that before you
engagement with anyone that's so
important
but they a good advisor
nad can can really transfer can really
transform your business
for me again it was a it was for the
business side of things i can scale and
say the things that
a lot i just the the strategy uh
i took my time from somebody who was a
scottish-based
non-executive some a good recruitment
experience but also found a real
a london-based guy who is a management
consultant a real
strategy kind of guy who helps work on
a capital events and exits as well so
really he's really helped us going to
transform that
just the look and feel of the business
we actually moved a little bit from
the nbn recruitment nbn recruitment to
mbn solutions but that was a welcome
thought out strategy we looked at that
and it was just all about the events and
the white papers we were putting out it
was a lot of really industry stuff
as well so we got a lot of advice on
that but again
unless you've been here done it before
and really built and scaled something if
you've not got that experience or you've
not hired anybody without experience go
and find somebody who
knows how to do it then it can really
transform your business
of definite but they stay with the right
people because it's so important you
hear
so many horror stories as well yeah yeah
do you have any did you go into speak to
anyone that you like i don't know
not have any good experiences i went to
speak to a couple of people i start
in a and it didn't feel great
it it wasn't really what didn't feel
right about it was it that you just did
you feel like they were just trying to
sell you something i don't know what i
did right i think it's like i've i've
turned on exact directors who haven't
i've been on and i've been holdings with
them now i've went on
endurance events with them i've gone
with them personally
uh and professionally as well i think
it's quite important it was quite
important to me as a because i'm
a people's person to to really kind of
fight people who are going with but
again like
you can find amazing people who can help
you with certain parts of your journey
then
you can look at other people for
different journeys doesn't i think it
just depends where you are at the moment
if you're looking at
processes and systems find somebody who
knows
who can do that inside though it doesn't
need a big entrepreneur
strategy strategic consultant it could
be somebody who was a
high level ops person within a business
before we speak to somebody at the
moment who's been
absolutely amazing for us i think i
could tell that right now it's like
wow some of the stuff they're bringing
because they've done that and their job
for five six years
uh just find people just find out what
you need
where you want to take the business uh
you might need maybe a couple of years
solid work with them to get to here then
you might look at a different journey
that's quite important i love that
so talk before we finish then talk to me
about
what's been your journey what's been
your i guess let's start like what's
been your biggest challenge
in growing this business from a higher
like bringing people on the bus
and having them in the right seats like
what what's been your biggest challenge
there because i get
sort of messages all the time on sort of
people who may be at that sort of
5 10 15 mark and really struggle to get
anywhere past 20
they're always sort of yo-yoing like
talk to me a bit about
what what have you had to learn the hard
way yeah in terms of
hiring the right people to talk to us
about that yeah
i've found a happy definitely really
really helped
learn to have you like most like a lot
of people can be uh
i think you always you
used to always be a massive emphasis on
people's balance and what they could
build and what they could
bring in financially and a lot of the
other characteristics and traits were
great
yeah and that could be a recipe for
disaster so i think for us it's
it's been a massive learning curve
honestly
we could sit and talk about this all day
i've really over the past
the past while really trying to
i think people who are quite purpose-led
people as well people who have got a
real kind of passion for people
and a passion for what what the what
they what they do
and are looking for a bit of longevity
within a career what what what did you
find yourself
looking at before was it just just order
about 200 about 300.
don't even really need to interview them
they'll be fine as long as it can bring
in numbers
that was the probably what i was kind of
brought up with back then which is
it then it worked well for me but how
that has as well
i've i've hired different people who
have got really good kind of
family models as well one of kind of top
builders at the moment is
as a young guy
tried football professional football but
he could have fell into recruitment he
actually wrote me one of these letters
mr young could i'm
interested in i was like caught my eye
and i brought him in but he's really
motivated to his family he's getting
really good paychecks at the moment even
don't give his mom a car there and all
that and looks after his car
stuff like that as well i think i'm
starting to really look for people who
are quite similar minded
and i know it's it might not be a beyond
endo for
massive you know companies are looking
for like higher 30 40 50 people in scale
scale scale but
the the way i'm going to do at the
moment is bringing in
good professionals decent people who are
good with clients i'm not going to mess
with clients about and really go
well with them and and deliver or if
they don't deliver they'll talk about
why they're not delivering
it's so important have you experienced
typically have you experienced typically
more
um people that have recruitment
experience rather than not
most of working a lot of our kind of
talk people at the moment of people are
brought in without any recruitment
experience at all
but recently this year
i've been focusing on experience i'd
love to take on grads and rookies at the
moment
but we're just fully remote and
scotland's still at the moment and
trying to work out work out the best way
to bring on people with no experience
but i've hired a few people who
have been experienced i've really took
my time but again
look at some clients i've worked with
get them to talk about some of those
the clients they work with you might
know some of them as well i know you
can't always do those reference checks
yeah but please do your due diligence
i've been i've hired some really good
people who have really taken my time and
i've actually
i've even come after them who've
identified who they are and after them
ourselves and
and really trying to come and persuade
them to come and join us because we know
that
they're good but again it's hard i've
had a few really good experiences late
lately but who knows what the future
will hold us yeah i've been using this
spq spq tool at the moment as well which
has been
what's that the exact personality
it's gonna it's a it's a recruitment
specific one
yeah is it closed people find out
because it's quite a good one and
they'll give the guy a
plug what's what's good about it why
it's a real recruitment one and a and
it's it's been right
so many times for us at the moment it's
made us maybe not hire people just
before we've been ready to pull this
trigger
that showed us some small concerns with
people before they've joined
which helped us really uh really
do a training round about it yeah like
help on that yeah what so what types of
things i have interested what types of
things
can it understand maybe like right
around about state
sales it could be stuff imposter
syndrome
cannot not it's been like a real sales
level stuff but it's really identified
some key strengths within like
customer experience and and
professionalism and stuff like that as
well which has been key for us and
recently a recent one was
where we have hired someday and we
went back after they've been with us for
a while and and and did the test that
that this one must have fell through the
day
i don't know why we've never done it but
we did it after they started
it and it really it was a great report
as
i knew it would be but it did show a
real
like it could be a great start but this
person could start getting overwhelmed
if they're too busy they could have too
much
and the the day later the guy they
phoned
up his mind said well i've got quite a
lot more look at my desk
there is a real science behind this and
again that's something i'm just starting
to
i think his name is dominic walters spq
but it's been
again it's a it's a recruitment one and
it's something the science behind
essence
it's a beauty we're really learning the
science behind everything at the moment
yeah i'll definitely i'll definitely
find out what that tool is
i'll pull it we'll get it in the show
notes because i know
it's stuff like that people are really
interested in
support so as we finish then talk to me
about
how are you feeling about continuing to
cultivate
the nbn culture in this sort of
it seems like you're going down the
report remote in the office like how are
you feeling about as a business owner
i'm interested
like how are you there any are there any
things that you're doing on a weekly
monthly basis to ensure that
that culture is still there i don't know
how you're feeling about it so
nervous all a little bit as well but i'm
quite excited about the future at that
moment i
honestly i've done a lot of can i work
on myself probably over the past 18
years 18 months day to two years i've
done a lot of
i've really liked myself taking a handle
making a pressure on stresses i've been
writing
it crazy ultra runs and big challenges
and i've done a lot of
the cold water exposure so i feel as if
i'm pretty common in meditation and all
that probably
don't know about our old happy these
days but it's really helped me
run the business more kind of
purpose-led and looking at the people
and
and seeing what good we can do with our
organization to help get other people as
well
so i i'm we're really looking
closely at our people and we will be
filling them all but we're looking at
doing a lot more kind of
days together when we can and bringing
people together
and again it's so i don't know i've just
really
we've always again it's i've always been
looking at a sales sale sales and this
company lunches and it's sales people
it's top hours top buyers but i was on a
i can accompany lunch there this might
be quite controversial for the
recruitment industry but a
company kind of sales one was launched
there and there was eight always on it
and i thought
i really feel as if our business and nba
is in a position where
it's much more than just the sales at
the moment but bob's is
really leaning on our finances leaning
in our markets
is marketing is really leaning in and i
feel as if
it's time now it can have to bring the
business into warning angus i don't know
if it's maybe other
recruitment currently doesn't business
people taking a listen to that
there's so much more than just the sales
within the business you do need that but
to get the kind of clog working it's got
to be
a one company in one team and i'm really
emphasizing
i'm pushing on that at the moment to try
and bring people together look at our
kind of values our strategy
what we're doing moving forward and and
leaning in because there's people you
know who
you're just keeping an eye out and
people there's people who are quiet
maybe there are days here and there the
odd week here
and it's really leaning and they make
sure they're okay they won't like it's
so important
i love that comment come a long way
since
never managing people don't know that
right
okay i'm very fortunate to love what i
do i do
still get as much passion today as i
have enough when i first started it's
just changing yearly monthly weeklies
good things
the market is the market is it's so busy
at the moment and
i feel as if it's it's the tides are
coming now with
good quality recruitment businesses and
recruitment consultants
can now pick and choose who they want to
work with
instead of instead
really really master your trade because
if you do you will be able to pick and
choose
the companies you want to work with
based on their values how they work
the hiring process all that kind of
stuff it's really
strong emphasis on quality over quantity
and and
looking at more can i retain stuff and
if you are an expert in your field you
should be getting paid for what you're
doing
from the start as well for years we've
been really contingency and
busting our busting our jobs doing a
great job and getting cracked
people through our process maybe a
month's work to to not get paid so what
can i mention at the moment is really
looking at how we can
change that um and and and what
what the companies that kind of share
their kind of values and work air force
as well
yeah i love that so the final final
question for you michael what's the
what's the ultimate goal for your
recruitment career yeah
just keep building at the moment uh take
the business more international
hire some real quality people get into a
position where we've got a
good more of a real solid structure
i create across sales
and and start bringing on more people
and see what we can see what else we can
do
to bring about a good in this world as
well where we're all been successful and
that's
important we'll share some of the
success with less
people are more less fortunate than
yourselves love it
michael thank you so much for coming on
the podcast good
thanks for